janice dean is our senior meteorologist
here at fox she lost both of her in-laws
in facilities
licensed by new york state to the
coronavirus she knows a lot about this
topic and she joins us tonight janice
thanks so much
for coming on i don't want to run rub
salt in this very fresh wound but to
hear
the governor of new york pass the buck
on to the president for his decision
how do you respond to that
he's blamed everybody except the person
that signed the mandate the order to
bring covid patients into nursing homes
and that was andrew cuomo
he signed the order at the very
beginning he said listen if you have a
problem with what happens in new york
you blame me the buck stops at my desk
he has never taken any responsibility or
accountability
and as you just played he has blamed
everyone except
himself god mother nature he's blamed
fox news
he's blamed the new york post mother
nature
it never ends and today he continued to
blame fox news
and says there doesn't need to be an
independent investigation because the
last
investigation was done by himself into
his administration and of course
he came up clean the people to blame
were the nursing
care workers and the visitors and by the
way
we weren't allowed to visit my in-laws
before they died
so i don't believe that one so you
live in new york you work in new york
your family was devastated
by this decision have you had a chance
to tell governor cuomo that
no i had a chance to speak today i
filled out all the paperwork and i sent
letters
to assembly men and lawmakers
new york state lawmakers for the
hearings today they were actually
august the third last monday and today
they couldn't fit me in last monday but
they said that they would put me
on today to give me my five minutes to
talk about my in-laws
and why i hold the governor partly
responsible for their deaths
um that invitation was rescinded
after you know i was told that the chair
said you will have
your five minutes and and i never got
that today so i thank you tucker for
being good on your word
and having me on your program today
we're always delighted to have you on
the show janice
even under sad circumstances like this i
appreciate your coming on and i'm really
sorry once again
thank you for following the story i
appreciate it thank you